I think one of the great myths is that
we are over diagnosing and over treating
and over medicating the children of
America nothing could be further from
the truth
while there's tremendous increase in the
identification of something like
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
and therefore more children able to get
a hold of medication the overwhelming
majority do not get identified and don't
get treated the good news is that these
medicines have been available since the
1930s
no one has ever died of taking a psycho
stimulant like adderall or dexedrine or
Ritalin and more importantly kids who
get treated early are less likely to use
illicit drugs than kids who don't get
treated or kids who get treated late
when you have ADHD and it makes perfect
sense if you don't diagnose and treat a
real psychiatric illness and a kid feels
demoralized and feels irritable and
feels terrible about themselves and
about their self-esteem the psychiatric
medicines don't work they start treating
themselves with alcohol with marijuana
with cocaine with ecstasy with illicit
drugs with cigarettes and so ignoring
these disorders and worrying about the
fact that we're medicating too much when
in reality I think we need to get better
at identifying kids when they're in
trouble recognizing that these are not
feel-good medicines they have no
straight you know they're you know take
this pill take this Prozac you'll feel
better in six weeks you know it has no
street value is really a problem and
that America has to get their head
around the fact that psychiatric illness
is real and at times needs not only real
treatments like cognitive behavioral
therapy or behavioral treatment or
whether it's remediation or
accommodations for learning but also
needs medications at time and with
medication there's always the risk of
side effects and the potential of of a
positive effect at the end of the day
we'll let a child or a teenager truly
live to truly be able to live a full
life at work at school at play and in
love you know
with friends and with her family